I like first of all congrats on the
movie I like throwing some curve balls
at the beginning and considering you've
been speed dating with a lot of people
uh let's you're our favorite so far I
appreciate that so um if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before besides this movie which
obviously is the easy answer what would
you like them watching first and why Wow
Wow that's that's a good question of
everything you know I guess I'd have to
say if you like this movie then maybe um
there's a show called winning time
there's two seasons of it and and it's
got a similar feel and so may maybe that
one and it was most recent I did yeah uh
I would say um there's a movie I did
called tramps with Adam Leon and uh it
was my first American lead uh I was 25
and I think doing that movie was was
it's such a special moment for me
because it was when I decided yeah I
really want to become an actor what is
the most nervous you've been the night
before the first day of filming wow that
I I've definitely got one for the it was
this movie I did called pale blueee and
I it was the first day of shooting and I
had to cry in the arms of Christian Bale
and I was I was having a panic attack uh
and I think I got one hour of sleep but
then he was the loveliest and it was
great probably that I did I did a movie
called Green Room and my Visa didn't
come for some reason until the last
minute and I jumped on a flight to
Seattle and everyone else I played the
lead singer in the band and everyone
else had been bonding and and getting to
know each other and I just felt so out
of place and out of touch and I remember
uh basically just bricking it and being
in somewhere in a St near Storia and
seeing Antonin aliia sh and Joe Cole
come across this car park at like 12:30
and they were just they was so beautiful
and we went on and had a beautiful time
jumping into why I get to talk to you
guys after making this and you were on
the water a bunch did you have do you
now have more respect for Spielberg and
Jaws making that movie on the water back
in the 70s with like you know film no
digital cameras and Antiquated
technology if you will absolutely I mean
first of that's my favorite Spielberg
movie uh and I already have the most
amount of respect for him for that movie
uh you know the truth is George was so
prepared doing this that for us it felt
seamless for him he'll tell you it was
almost a math to work out how to do it
and him and Martin Ru uh um yeah they
they they made it so seamless for us you
know the difficult thing for us was in
know for our job was just to roll you
know and so we would race for a
kilometer and then have to turn around
and roll back and reset and then race a
kilometer and it was just excruciatingly
painful um but you can see that in the
film oh 100% one of the things about
both of you in this film is you do a lot
of the talking and you do like none of
the talking and so I'm just curious it
was great I had no lines to
that there was no studying the night
before but talk a little bit about both
of your characters because you're doing
the heavy lifting in the relationship
but you also have to emote so much with
just your face and your eyes um can you
sort of both talk about that well yeah
well said um I think I think Joyce is uh
well aware of the fact that he's shy and
she sort of follows him to school um and
so I think she does a lot of the talking
cuz she's sort of poking and prodding
and sort of you know seeing if seeing
what's going kind of testing the waters
H that was that was I I did a little pun
there CU oh I'm sorry that was so good
terrible of testing the waters and the
relationship and finding a balance there
yeah you know for
me I someone that was really
inspirational for me for this part was
Gary Cooper in High Noon especially Mr
Deeds I just love that guy as an actor
and and he was sort of an embodiment of
masculinity at that time and uh I
basically just ripped him uh and Spencer
Tracy Too was a big uh influence um and
and and I guess energetically to Woody
Guthrie and the music of Woody Guth and
the feeling at the time um uh This Land
Is Your Land I listen to on repeat every
morning almost as a Gateway back into
1936 one of the things that did not
realize was how big the sport of rowing
was at the time it's like basketball and
football now so talk a little bit about
what you learned researching this era
and researching these characters um that
really surprised you I mean I think that
actually the fact that they would draw
100,000 spectators at pyy just to come
and watch a ring race I mean our
equivalent would be Oxford and Cambridge
and and in London uh and they don't get
anywhere near the level um that these
guys did for me the sport itself you
know I truly fell in love with it and uh
it was hard and arduous and excruciating
and painful but um with hindsight I can
see how special it is and and the thing
that I'll never do anything like this in
a movie again they set us up to succeed
it was like being part of a professional
sports team and uh I made a bomb with
these guys that is going to last
forever yeah yeah ABS I mean it was a
really popular sport back then and I
don't really know why it kind of dropped
off I don't know when I don't know why
because it's just so exciting to watch
it's like completely riveting and on the
water it's also just aesthetically
beautiful you know which a lot of sports
don't really capture that kind of magic
and um but who knows maybe this movie
will bring it back you know you want to
row now you've seen this I know I'm not
physically fit enough to do the rowing
after watching you do it oh I wasn't
when I started yeah like it that that is
a beast of a sport yeah you know what I
mean I've got so much respect for those
guys and now when we you know cuz the
own Community has sort of welcomed us as
a film and accepted us and I'm like wow
I feel so small in comparison you guys
are absolute like Olympians and I'm just
like poy Brit one of the things though
is that and and what I found so
interesting because it's obviously based
on a true story is they were literally
like your character was literally rowing
to survive it wasn't just a sport to him
he was this was his food this was his
lodging this was his university can you
sort of talk about this is like
borderline life or death yeah you know
the thing that got me and broke my heart
about Joe rans is when he was 13 years
old he came home from school the car's
running his stepmom's in the front
siblings are in the back and his dad's
on the porch and he says Dad where are
we going and his dad says we're going
you're not and he was 13 years old and
he was left to fend for himself in Squam
you know he he stayed in the same house
but it was basically an abandoned house
they took all the stuff out he fished
for salmon in the river just to survive
he bust on the street and he put himself
through school and I was just so
inspired by this determination and the
grit and the desire to achieve something
and not just to survive but to thrive
and um and then through that attitude he
ended up in this boat and you know Joe
rant for me is the True Underdog Story
of this you know of life you know and uh
um it was an honor to play him on that
note I'm going to have to stop and just
say congrats on the movie wish you guys
nothing but the best and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating thank you
and you too by the
way